tout ça c'est horrible je voulais dire
non mais la partie ben oui c'est gênant
pour les blancs mais ça demande encore
faire un peu gaffe tout ça parce qu'en
fait il veut lui faire alors de tourner
ici ce qui allait f3
là il va faire plonger et 6 3 le mandat
ce qui pouvait pas jouer pour contrer
cet effet ou machin to b de grattage
quelque chose ou alors ici la trouver
quelque chose que tu es maintenant tu
menaces rien pas un écart et f3 g2 oui
enfin la sema th 7 quand même non mais
oui mais comment son fils roger 2 ça va
voilà c'est juste sa pièce bien ses
pions de plus assez fine food et 5 reste
intéressant de voir comment sa structure
aussi il va dans les parties on peut pas
toujours être bien malheureusement est
de savoir qu'on se débrouille dans les
poubelles un peu des strikers qui a
essayé de faire pour ça va suffire mais
là c'est fini
des cinq bessette le connais mon avis
devrait limiter le temps
c'est à dire limiter le temps déjà ouais
mais je vous le temps en fait non mais
ces crèmes tout pour faire ce à quoi la
mais le truc c'est que j'ai choisi je
sais que trois plus un c'est vraiment la
cadence de saut donc moi ils vont jouer
bach appuie les heureux saïd le ça aussi
on veut dire c'est la stratégie de match
pas très beau mais pas illégal
non non c'est enfin en fait c'est même
normal entre guillemets c'est juste
avant on a déjà parlé mais il faudra pas
y apprend en dessin des défauts du truc
quoi c'est un peu étrange en soi mais
bon ça veut dire que ces cinq partout
fab 5 partout et c'est combien de temps
3.5 1h 1h ouais en fait plus à cadencer
longue normalement moins tu as deux
parties logique logique mais toujours su
quoi il retourne un peu denses et
italienne assure difficile de juger
elles paraissent tellement tout
ressemblant que les unes aux autres
salam sur des nuances ressemblant et je
pense que lloris est correct pour course
au jeu peut-être m me mettre à jouer
l'italienne dit pourquoi pas en fait
j'aimerais jouer italienne et française
à voilà qui revient 3ème essai est
persuadé c'est marrant ce truc là en
fait avec les noirs tu sais tu dis je
vais ramener où qu'ils aillent en f4 et
toucher du kalyev quattro j'arrive
non pas du tout mais qui te fait un
fouet fff ou noam je vois pas le matin
et tu vas jamais en fait oui tu peux
ramener autant de pièces que tu es en
fait foi fou nos cavaliers et tres bon
banquier proche 3 juste ça va et puis on
bouge on apprend mais pour la française
tu veux une vraie française du fer des
premières dames hier testing blague par
rapport au fait que je réponds
italien un nathan le découpage française
n'a rien changé
c'était un trait d'humour dommage ça
aurait pu vouloir passe comme ça mais
j'étais bien on fera tous les vrais
échecs passerez vos que soit ce que 4,6
des 4,5 puis bon alors et s'il ya un
faux problème 5 puis en province avec ma
fille qui avait lieu cette année donc il
va re re maintenir la menace hacker
prend h3 exactement il ya un truc
intéressant si tu n'as pas de jouer à 5
nuls et donc ça ça te permet de faire
quoi un jour très fermé ça peut très
vite et dans des finales si les blancs
avaient bloqué un c4 qui fasse b4 abcb1
sortes d'objets passé là bas mais allez
peut-être des fous b dos aussi un des
trucs comme ça c'est pas courant passait
quasiment un coup automatique toit de
fer à 5 pas au québec le bloc ont pas
l'espace mais c'est loin d'être certain
que ce soit si bien pour lui l'art de
faire bon d'ailleurs il l'a pas fait
mais c'est une vraie question à se poser
world tour cette sorte mg6 ouais mais je
pense que les noirs sont bien parce
qu'on regarde à la paire de fou femmes
yeux entrés ils ont plus de problèmes
la colonne des tu vas jamais la donne et
eu peut-être injuste un fou aussi c'est
tour huit mois ou fou 17 retour huit
jours mais le fond c'est 8 g pas j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya une position
vraiment très cool il peut y avoir du
dallage 5 qui barrent g5 gk toi même et
tu as raison en fait ceux-là ont trois
plus un mètre tu l'avais dit que c'était
sa cadence et c'est vrai qu'une nouvelle
fois tu as l'impression qui reprend le
dessus quoi bah là ça va il se fait pas
il se faire martyriser à la taille qui
sait pas il veut sur trop fofolle il
peut se mettre en place
et comme il au début en fait ouais
c'est à dire à dominer tranquille pas
faire de faute on veut dire qu'il fait
pas de fautes directes sommet que quand
il est un peu sous pression il peut il
peut craquer mais si tu l'attaquent pas
en fait il fait pas de faute quoi mais
je crois que le défaut c'est qu'ils
arrivent eux trop défendre
a priori un son réflexe je dis pas faim
il sait calculer c'est tout bien faire
mais des fois il serait flex de vouloir
blindés quoi bien joué c'est aussi très
vite dans le prince qui attaque et f2 au
fruité swan bonne diagonale dans tout le
blog tiens je change de diagonale et
c'est surtout la vitesse de réaction un
coup comme fou b6 nous aussi on trouve
mais il nous faut peut-être dix quinze
vingt secondes mais en fait ça tous les
systèmes pos et en plus il a sûrement vu
en vraiment en amont en plus il y avait
déjà prévu et s'est vite exécuté il a
déjà une minute d'avancé et mais c'est
marrant en fait que amecea ça c'est bien
joli si bon ouais ce que je vais dire
mais bien en b 6 mais là on voit le
point fort de naka par contre c'est à
dire peu de temps à la pendule et c'est
un coup ils menacent ils s'activent et
il est très dangereux celui très bien
caché tapez 1 tapez à une envie de g5 g4
truc un peu fou fou avec tout ça peut
soit je vais pas trop faire des cinq
personnes reggie 5 t'attaques la dame
juste pour expliquer un g4 attaque
cavaliers tu joues sur le clouage
faisait peur de boeuf mais peut-être
changer cinq plus tu as de soissons
d'alger 3 au pirée sur gk tu n as rien
vérifié en fait de toute façon c'est
quoi qu'il en soit c'est un coup d'épée
dans l'eau
mais tu as la ffb 6 pouces et 7 comme
quoi où il faut c est surement pour une
fois ne l'oise peut-être ouais donc il
fait le f sinko dont tu parlais vallorbe
et si j'ai fait tous les coups et plus
tard l'armée nature avoir emmené ak
c'est impressionnant tout ce qui vient
de te faire un tempo en fait
ouais y voit tout il vient juste de te
retourner le truc sans réfléchir une
seule seconde et la sueur fou prend
aussi soin à voir jusqu'à et des catins
avec quelques louage ou fous ces quatre
je sais pas lequel est plus fort
faux b6 bon c'est chaud pour enlever ce
roi de la bam est ok on a toutes les
idées de la partie mais à retardement
bien le droit de gestion tout court
cassard est joué à rien fab jouer en
double dames prends tu peux apprendre à
tu peux peut-être prendre du cavalier et
y'a pas photo là je crois qu'il a raté
vous prendrez 3 il l'a raté il a raté il
a raté les deux quoi il a fait des
mouvements et pointe avec un retour
assez terrible le craquage un couple l
essai tout fait bouffer les uns que les
autres sont tombés comme des mouches
mais c'est marrant quoi il s'est épris
le foot pro f deux franges et trois fous
croyez qu'à toi le fou il a fait très
très mal
le flou logique résiste aux regards
étaient bien il reste à voir des
clouzeaux qe3 souvient bonté feu david
einhorn et ouais ok ok sa partie de max
compte nespouls la simko fille d'origine
et ouais avec le cavalier à 3 et tout ça
mais c'est marrant comment nakheel and
close et que la super bien joué pendant
25 coups avec une seconde
enfin en jouant quasiment avec une
seconde chaque coup et tout d'un coup
y'a juste explosé quand tu reprends le
5-fu preuve deux tours deux soupes range
étroit il a dû penser qu'il est tout
rejet de il avait pas ouais c'est un
truc c'est là tu as accès psychologique
aussi des échecs et tac tac tac qui ont
raté un truc tu est dégoûté 7
c'est comme le puzzle rush en fait quand
tu es chaud thé chaud thé chaud tu fais
une erreur
bon c'est pas grave n'aurait sibeam tu
fais des 3 dans les prochains mois trois
d'affilée de nerfs mais tu perds le flou
mais c'est moins qu'à la fin c'est
vraiment c'est psychologique mais à la
fois c'est peut-être aussi physiologique
dans le sens où peut-être que parfois on
a juste des baisses de régime du cerveau
et ça le montre des baisses de régime
belge cheval comme quand tu cours
parfois on était un peu essoufflée tu
vas t'asseoir
30 40 secondes et tu repars et des fois
mettre son cerveau c'est tata besoin de
la balle était tombée quoi ouais mais tu
as besoin de gérer mais ouais ça peut
être un peu comme un cas ou mirettes a
besoin de récupérer juste cnjc peut-être
pas vains psychologique oui parce que ça
a un rapport avec l'esprit donc on
emploie toujours le mot
psychologiquement réalité c'est
peut-être plus physique tu vas dans quel
sens je veux le dire mais à oslo qui
avait remis sa veste il arait enlève non
on ne sait jamais trop haute mais l'ami
les lunettes aussi pour le 3 + 1
devinette de trois plus un conseil
général mais ça on ne pourra plus un jeu
mais tu avais tu l'enlèves que mes
lunettes chez les élèves et tous mais
c'est bizarre on n'accueille encore
énervé sur la gamme de la partie
précédente
bah c'est rare de le voir craquer comme
ça ça montre aussi la valeur de wesley
un atout j'ai bien l'impression de naka
écoute j'ai l'impression qu'il a bien
fermé le jeu allèles dame que la case
des cinq les blancs ils apprennent
jamais et wave avoir faire payer ses 500
prend d'options à 400 prendre option de
4% que c'est juste un fiasco pour pour
les blancs mais je te sens ouais changer
ses comptes 2 1 à kayes de nouveaux
énervé l'après foot france et 4 life et
des pâquis les français ah oui ils
étaient choqués que il a refait un signe
de tête après tout il était dégoûté de
france et 4 est dégoûté de tours et
après
les origines des deux là je sais pas on
n'a pas le redis pour analyser en même
temps mais toi je vais te dire je joue
comme ça sur foot français gagnent moi
j'aurais pris sans trop réfléchir
mais lord batum et un coût de l'ordre
mais les valses et quoi marquer - 0-15
et qu'il pense et 4 dames 1er 3 pour le
faire c'était moins 0,42 après celle
ordi de machin non plus le génie mais ça
donne une idée mairie l'alarmé temps
mais c'est hyper complexe parce qu'il ya
peut-être fou prend cavaliers prend et
car il est des cinq malades partout le
tapis on a passé à tabac bon fond f3 qui
peut re de sympa ça redevient je sais
pas mais bon je crois que c'est bien
pour les normes reims tours benjamin
sans que ça fait cher sommes qu'à cinq
tours b 8 c'est vraiment falloir des
noirs parce que t'as pas de casse pour
le fou alors qu'est ce que tu fous à 3
tours points à 5
je vous prends dessus mais aucun moment
où j'avais demandé parce que je voulais
faire depuis tout à l'heure en fait
parce qu'au moins tu tues mais le cas
est sous pression tu mets des six sous
pression bah non c'est la cas depuis le
début
l'ouverture se fait cueillir trois quais
des deux essais 4e 3ème premier rang des
100 capes de dames cette dame française
option français de tourcoing 4e rang des
cinq attentats taxés deux tatas que 4 et
sur cavaliers des deux tu veux juste
qu'il est français du genre y'a pas de
données la qualité
non mais tu veux pas ce troquet les
s'accroche un saut je sais pas s'il va
la tenir mes positions qu'elle a hyper
dur à jouer il a lâché comme ça un truc
c'est qu'il vous vend 6 vengeur des six
il récupère des ir fait le fou magique
au g20 il ya d'ailleurs il va me mettre
une tour en d4 à la fin sur mon et je
pourrai gagner cette partie de mes deux
[Rires]
rivaux qu'ils refassent ça et je pense
que là il est très énervé ci fais ça
il casse sa machine derrière lui les
faits
je crois qu'il va tenir wesley ce que
fout parce que ce n'est même pas lui qui
pressent un peu normal oui non c'est
complètement nul mais j'aime bien et
c'est toujours nous demander qui est du
côté de la banque cotée quoi de la nuls
9 mai après chance que là c'est les deux
sont du bon côté
peut-être quatre ces parages verrez - tu
te se débarrasse de ce gros centres mais
du côté du club je vais très très très
longtemps cela c'est sa stratégie de
limiter d'être au plus prêt contre eur
après contre sow faut faire garde de ne
pas se faire contrer dans les trucs
quand tu après peut-être qu'on bullet
c'est plus facile à jouer pour hikaru
dans le sens où tu attaques un peu le
roi paris bull est parce qu il ya plus
de temps ou c5 c'est bien joué parce
qu'il va faire le sais tape avec des 4
et du coup ils couvrent les cases du
cahier où il va faire tourner ensuite
tout jeune fou j'en ai tellement bien
placé il fait la focale sur le cavalier
c'est pas ça semble dangereux mais
absent que ce soit pour pour faire ces
forteresses à à temps mais c'est ce que
j'allais dire en fait l'option de bélie
passe il a essayé de le mater son four
17h17 ça j'avais vu mais en fait il va
se faire choper le pion quand même à
ingénieux nous aider pour faire du bon
cinéma tu veux faire mais il y aura un
peu moins mega python handicap moteur
mais oui ça va durer longtemps
normalement car il y avait deux je pense
qu'il va faire elle va pas échanger il
va du jeu pendant cent coups non mais ce
qui gêne c'est qu'il va être même pas au
score
on est très content il a fait un il a
fait un truc qui fait pas l'habitude
quoi y'a des trucs vraiment content pas
en mode dance mais en mode jeu l'arraché
quoi c'est terrible c'est terrible pour
wesley ouais mais il est très aisé
tresserre avait l'effet des signes très
bizarre et que sa tête il est très fou
marrant ce lac a quand même j'aime bien
les laroquais donc ça fait 6 partout il
reste 40 minutes c'est ça dans cette
cadence reste juste à les voires reste
36 mise ouais ça peut presque ce que
j'imagine le temps passe vite quand ça
joue bien comme ça donc là c'est de
nouveau les mêmes italienne un copain
position source
un petit peu différente mais c'est les
mêmes styles de position 5e en fait
c'est les deux font que 4,5 alors 30 ans
tanaka qui nous sommes petit nas d'or
sortie de nom sinon ce qu'elle me 4 au 5
e 4 e 5 e 4 e tu vas pas retourné
d'ailleurs sur la neige d'or finalement
bassi vu des positions qui sont un peu
plus compliquées pourquoi pas le
déséquilibre et tu penses quoi du choix
stratégique de sow qui changent du tour
germes qui s'était bien passé jeu se
veut brûler parce que généralement match
tu dois retourner non parce que
maintenant on fait le problème c'est que
flany m'avait expliqué ce truc
d'ouverture de cartes c'est qu'en fait
maintenant ouverte à carquefou 2 août a
perdu donc t'as pas envie de retourner
dessus et dont structure gien tulle à
paris ouverte et donc du coup si tu
repères c'est dur psychologiquement en
soi donc du coup en fait c'était logique
de ces logiques en fait deux
bah ce truc on change pas une équipe qui
gagne quoi de bombarder le truc est de
changer quand tu perds parce qu'en fait
si tu gagnes une deuxième fois tu fermes
manager pour lui et là tu est le seul
cas où tu changes c'est souvent le
contenu aussi mais en fait la partie
c'est juste bien passé il a gagné mais
il a mérité
oui oui bien sûr c'est pas je suis tour
gère je fais défoncer ou la chance je
gagne et la bombe fédéraux y vont en
fait j'ai eu beaucoup de chance je
retourne pas j'ai compris mais en fait
non c'est juste bien besoin c'est pour
ça oui c'est vu le scénario de la partie
et tout ça tu te dis pas tu peux
retourner dessus et poser des questions
à l'autre après c'est les joies que les
joueurs changent beaucoup mais après un
plus haut à les deux faces que je
comprends pas c'est que je suis passé et
puis que t'as pas trop le temps de la
fille des fichiers entre les parties
ouais surtout tour g1
si vous voulez jouer la finale avec des
cinq le truc connu il aurait il tu peux
pas check et très longtemps puisque ce
n'est pas la vente qu'il a joués jury la
page de la grande borne donc super
intendante c'est pas en trois minutes
que tu va réviser tous et savoir ce
qu'on t'a préparé donc le choix était
sembler étrange très bons essais qui
remet à peut-être un peu de pression
jamais imposition des femmes j'aime bien
je trouve que les noirs sont bien
sorties l'ouverture à moins de 24 sur le
medrek cinq héritiers pas moins bien oui
c'est une position très symétriques un
des pions sont complètement symétrique
l'on peut dire que la dame en c5 un peu
mieux placé que la dame en d2 et qui a
réussi c'est un peu mieux placé que le
cas et j'ai trois mois après non mais
bon égal mais d'énormes souffrances ton
était bien sorti avec deux ouvertures
on va choisir ils mordent les qualifs 4
ou et 5 pourquoi le mec prennent pas
alors que lui tout se dire ça reprenne
en fait en train de serrer père de fou
dans ce qu'elle a et ce à travers un
pion la bague que de donner une sorte de
majorité aider d'autres data qui est à
la case aux quatre pour être des pièces
va faut voir ça va vraiment me sylla les
noirs faire qu'après 9 5 qui ont près
900 et conduit par eux quatre ça serait
super pour les noirs faut pas qu'ils
aient ça mais là ils avaient paré là il
avait plutôt les 15,4 pour les cavaliers
après ton va lécher 4h 4 et 5 est en
général le truc c'est que s'il ya fait
toute cette fougue qui pensent qu'avec
l'appui toutes pièces blanches soit dix
ans a retrouvé trois ou quoi sattler en
force
là c'est intéressant parce que sur dame
premier veut faire dame prend pions
prend inquiets et c5 et temps énormément
de l'uqtr en c5 est juste parfait parce
qu'il attaque les deux points faibles
alors après à calculer ce que tu as le
temps de faire crisser 4 la preuve c'est
que west attaquer ces cas mais peut-être
bon tpr 1,4 dépensé 3 qui est points 4
ce que j'étais en train par exactement
la même veine que toi et des quatre
mains je prends donc bon là c'est un peu
relevé mais bon
après c'est encore une position style so
il va essayer de ramener en d3 si peu
mais bon comme b4g mais rejetant pêche
qui avait 3 kg 5 et d 3 points ok bien
jouer de faire avant d'autres on m'a
viré fils cadet des trois intermédiaires
est ce que je suis en train de me dire
ce que c'était bien joué ou passe d'être
un intermédiaire mais tu prends cinq
étapes à un truc là ouais c'est terrible
ce que tu reprends à 8 sur les chèques
sont alertés pour se suffire
c'est une bonne façon tour c'est un tour
descartes à et va retomber
ah ouais tour des huit tours à huit
il va prendre le sait trop bien joué de
la part des 2 un jeu de part et d'autre
non wacken des superbes parties fable ce
soir mais ça que ces mecs là en fait il
peut jouer contre dès que tu descends un
peu du top mondial se terminer en fait
la plus le niveau
c'est stratosphérique leur niveau de jeu
stratosphérique
ils ont eu des micros baisse de régime
les dom et cd baissent même leur baisse
de régime elle dure une deux parties max
et cédé face et db c'est tant mieux
mais anna k qui nous fait du grand naka
non ça ça qu'est ce que le beau match
détrompe toi c'est le plus beau moment
du match
détrompe-toi fabien des tombes toi la
stratégie toute la finesse
mais du coup on fait ça donne un statut
un peu l'idée de leur format parce que
leur format c'est de donner de l'
avantage à celui qui mène au score mais
en fait si tu es plus forts en bulles
est d'avantagé que ça finisse par le
bull est ce que toi tu peux plus jouer
le temps pas du coup ça ça augmente
encore l'importance du bullet par
rapport aux autres qu'à lens mais c'est
beaucoup restait à réfléchir oui c'est
de la gagner face et bar en bas je
comprends il doit se dire que s'ils
essayent un peu de la gagne et ifrane eu
le plus vite sur ce qu'il fera h quatre
échecs
oui mais bon pour nul 1
au moins on en parle plus que
franchement j ce qui se passerait bien
qu'il a peur mais c'est du rappeur ouais
mais bon
non non c'est le noir ouais
[Musique]
je pense qu'il va faire mais j'étais son
futur fait vrai en fait il faut faire
mieux qu'en mai j'aurais pu dire tu as
peu de temps je suis roi g4 f5 j'essaie
de te faire tomber mais bon je vais pas
y arriver il va repartir pour cinq ans
de coups mais wes al alawi là je suis
d'accord enfin en vérité je suis
d'accord avec toi les gens vitrolles
quoi il est très heureux
une fois deux parties mais magnifique
inoubliable
après so il fait pareil je te dire ouais
mais quand tu mènes de 28 points et qui
a plus aucun dans le match je comprends
mais là en fait sa demande si je oui oui
mais c'est un énième défaut du format ça
a des défauts du format un lacet c'est
dur de blâmer les joueurs en fait
bref the gay mais il connaît ou pas je
suis pas chez moi battant justice a
perdu option qui l'énervé fâcheuses pour
20 ouais je ressens qui l'énervé du truc
écueil tilt pas ça injuste de la merde à
ce qui s'est passé juste tokyo s'est
énervé
il s'est énervé
mata les pas d'un rock
regardez les choses comme ça tu disais
le chat ne réagit pas face à face je
suis arrivé trop tard dessus en fait par
rapport à naka qui qui bouge les pièces
comme ça quand je suis arrivé trop tard
pour voir le chat au nom mais pour moi
cela redore ainsi plus t'es pas d échec
puisque c'est pas un format qui a lieu
aux échecs n'ont donc finalement tu peux
changer les codes et que c'est peut-être
pas un manque de respect ce juge la
stratégie de match certainement mais non
mais moi je vois pas comme un manque de
respect je vois comme une limite au
format en fait ouais moi c'est plus ça
je trouve pas de soi qui sont en manque
de respect en fait juste il utilise les
règles mais je veux dire par là que si
dans n'importe quel match correct à
terme mais qui veut utiliser ces règles
là savent que tu as un problème en amont
ce concept reçoit le match il est pliée
d'avancé du coup c'est pas intéressant à
regarder
et quand c'est intéressant à regarder du
cou et ses séries tu te tapes des trucs
qui sont complètement loufoque en fait
qu'ils doivent pas arriver mais bon peu
importe mais non non par rapport à port
anna k qui le fais moi je trouve ça
légitime et normal en fait là dessus
c'est juste que c'est c'est comme ça
après c'est dommage que so i sort de son
match à cause de ça mais là encore comme
je suis et les échecs c'est
psychologique c'est mental il n'a pas à
sortir du match à cause de ça c'est à
lui de gérer son match mais là il à
faire la partie allait vraiment
catastrophique côté blanc c'est une
catastrophe ouest saharien neuf jours -
et puis ainsi qu'à de bien placé bon
après faut encore gagner mais non se
gagnent dans les cordes de jean tonio
khalid et 4 pour le moment il n'y a pas
de fou prend 5 et 3 parce que c'est lié
à la tour qui bouge complexe comme
dirait etienne je suis fière quand il
dit complexe
je veux pas du tout rebondir dessus
j'aime bien ça ça clôt complètement le
débat quoi complexe était une affaire
d'expression comme sa spectaculaire
terrible complexe je viens c'est un peu
muretain cesc comme comme phrase surface
il doit adorer ça complexe l'aï
complètement raide un temps mais attend
et il avait le cavalier cette e-menace
et du coup ça a forcé le truc et du coup
il à roye b si ce qui arrive
ah oui mais c'est très bien joué en
réalité assez plus si claire fabre a eu
droit jusqu'à et des six tout ça oui non
mais pour ces histoires de deux formats
en fait c'est juste devoir faire déjouer
des échecs comptant alors ce jeu en
point
c'est juste spéciale ouais c'est la
question du jour l'entente médard le
tennis quand tu vois les trucs en temps
parce que j'ai regardé un résumé ce
matin de tennis tension fait les
exhibitions ils ont tenté en temps c'est
ridicule tu as des matches à 18 11 il
reste trois minutes à jouer enfin face
et même plus des points fait avec les
joueurs ils s'en fichent voiture
électrique parce qu'on pouvait service
pour bien répondre oui oui mais c'est
extraordinaire en fait c'est mais c'est
des buildings entend pas je comprends
que pour les constructeurs versio c'est
bien parce que tu vends une plage de
temps et pas tu n'avances pas mais juste
de ses cousins mettre fin à sa force
c'est pas un truc qui fait progresser la
télé plaisir un spectateur qui doit les
regarder
ouais si c'est fait pour m sinon ça
disparaisse et à personne qui regarde
non mais tu as des gens qui vont
déballer déjà des gens qui regardaient
soit en train de détruire la beauté
enfin le truc qui était intéressant pour
faire un truc très hasardeuse
mais en fait ça dépend du système de
comptage des méta d'état des sports qui
sont plus fait pour le système de
comptage en temps et d'autres qui sont
plus souvent les sports collectifs
d'ailleurs et d'autres pour l'essai ce
montant c'est comme ça et c'est comme si
bann match de foot ça joue pour mieux
marquer des buts ça ça va casser indie
ça va casser une famille fait à des
trucs qui sont fait pour l'inde autre
pour l'autre ou la pétanque tu joueras
entend ce serait ridicule c'est pas
grave c'est juste le sport est fait
comme ça donc c'est jouer à autre chose
en fait de choses mais c'est enfin je
suis d'accord avec toi mais là où je
suis pas d'accord parce que je veux
c'est pas une question de jouer à autre
chose c'est juste que tu as des jeux
qu'ils défendent et des jeux et des
sports qui ce qui qui ont un système de
comptage qui va plus pour le temps et
d'autres pour les points en fait c mais
du coup ça se sent rennais briand fait
assez en deux matches quoi tac aux
échecs tu vas pas joué douze mille coups
pour faire quand même nul et être en
doit pas donner enfin une finale nul
tout près de perdre 1 pour faire nul on
trouvait en fait en fait tu arrives au
truc que je que je veux dire dans le
sens où en fait la nature du jeu fait
que la nature de la manière dans
laquelle tu organises des matches ne
peut pas être comme ça en fait tu va à
l'encontre de la nature du jeu en fait
c'est ça arrive à la gagne j'espère pas
mais je veux dire par là que nakai est
pour rien et je pense qu'il souhaitait
et bekaert je pense qu'ils expliquaient
oui je veux dire par la cnacg à lui dans
le choix de naka c'est un choix
complètement
donc c'est qu'on bronze aussi faible est
non compréhensibles a laissée je voulais
quand même le dire tu vois en fait en
gros y'a pas de soucis c'est tout le
monde je normalement comme si c'était un
truc normal mais en fait comme tout le
monde fait que ce café n'a qu'à plus ou
moins bien dans ces cas là mais c'était
ce que c'est que gagner sa gagne sa
balle optent plus c'était sûrement très
gagnant il ya pas longtemps mais là bas
on va se garer pour gagner lâche
agression
c'est ce que tu peux gagner 5 3 5 et 23
h d'autres temps est riche
couple europe il va te la rejouer
pendant cinquante coups n'ont pas leur
nom il a fait une fois un ehpad pas
assez de temps cette fois-ci 7,7
c'est une partie bizarre en autant que
nos commentaires on est à huit secondes
à divaguer quoi ça ça sort si tout le
monde du match les joueurs et tous qui
ont fait une mauvaise partie nous et
donc à 7 partout on va savourer ce jour
en bullet 1 dans tous les cas la coi qui
se passe de façon il reste combien de
temps mon fab ios il vaste il reste 19
noms qui restent
oui il reste quatre parties on va dire
bref avec son esprit il valait frais qui
essayent de gagner 3 cette petite phrase
pour le mans il mène d'un point dans le
3 + 1
l'échouage 4
ce qui va rejoindre un truc avec g5 je
sais pas ce que je pensais maintenant et
cavaliers h50 c'est celle là c'est le
type de situation j'aime j'aime bien
avec les noirs gh5 et tu peux te paierai
lancé f5 ou en tout cas tu vois
quelqu'un efficace tout ça c'est là
qu'est ce qu'il hésite pour kiev 5
arrive peut-être avoir dû h sinko sativa
h 5 h 5 h 4g 4 way
alors là c'est de nouveau le genre de
position qui ont plus favard détrompe
toi mon petit fabien assemat nackawic
entrerez sais je vais enfin j'ai un vrai
petit nul non je ne fais pas de nul
mais quelle étrange et trois en fait tu
forces km prend mais est ce que tu es
vraiment content de le forcer parce que
sur quelles preuves et si sa ket eux
deux ah oui non et je prends le vertueux
empêchait france oui non mais je vais
enfin que je voulais parler du f prend
airwatch en fait de tout à l'heure que
tu empêcher mais ce que ces tueries ce
que tu peux vraiment faire quelque chose
car j'ai craqué j'ai vu trois brèves
deux tours h un truc comme ça t'as pas
le temps de l'âge 5 ans inscrits au pied
levé 5 à 4 ces deux là sont obligés de
jouer au centre historique et noir il
faut d un mettons g3 roger 2 ça mais
est-ce que vous prendre trois si une
menace stratégique hausse en plus ce
sera peut-être ils veulent fermer mais
tu prends de f non si mal chez battre
prof
aucune idée le dam se bos humain bref on
va ou non c'était pour essayer de peut
être croiser mais je sens plutôt dame
semble plutôt dame bon choix
est ce que c'est vraiment un avantage
non ce truc là parce qu'en fait
visuellement tu te la rose hill et blanc
sont mieux mais est ce que c'est le cas
jusque dans l'autre côté tu vas avoir le
fourbe et 6 qui joue quand même bien au
final la colonnade je t'en fais pas
grand chose c'est bizarre ça tourne je
prends pas je veux l'échiquier clignoter
non c'est ma connexion est passée ta
connection intéresse comme ta voiture
marche très bien
notre armée nyad ce qui arrive à
l'arménie en fait c'est parce qu'il faut
mettre le match bah oui mais disons
qu'ils n'y étaient requises à l'internet
qui marchait donc arménien est quoi il
sait mouliom oui c'est moulée en très
gros joueurs
empreint de beaucoup d'autres joueurs
puisque tu te barres f6 sa monnaie pour
blinder montré qu est ce que tu te dis
je garde l'option fc contre les cases
blanches ces patrouilles seront 8
donc il arrive il a bien répondu à ma
question en fait il parce que je pense
que tu veux faire un petit train des
cuatro ou un truc du style mais en fait
en gros temps que je me sens pas au bout
de ses rêves si je te perds tu as tout à
fait raison mon avis vrai si un jour je
dois je dois on verra bien c'est
peut-être maintenant tu vas devoir si tu
veux essayer de progresser mais c'est
vrai que dès que tu fais un fils un jour
il ya une dame qui peut arriver à angers
6 mais je pense et des quatre trios doit
faire un nom
ça va être complexe à réussir il va lui
taper à 3 mais c'est terrible c'est
génial go vous c'est vraiment horrible
en fait il va vraiment lui taper en fait
c'est terrible ouais donc ils s'activent
de folie ils sont qui veut dame g5
intermédiaire champ suivant dame g5
d'amd de fab un moment donné ouais parce
que c'est une tournée de tordre et de
même plutôt désolé convaincant faire
tout reprend des citoyens mais ce que je
veux faire d'un projet 42.4 jeu mettra
le ranger un chemin dans bf3 tu va
couvrir chouette dame pranger 3g pas
c'est hyper chaud et d'autres calculs et
on va tourner 2 h
ok bon et active mais oui c'était page 5
sous avait anticipé ça je pense ici pour
s'apprécier tranquille et c'est fun
personnellement c'est quoi h5 je trouve
que c'est très bien joué parce que tu
t'attends à tour d2 avec les plantes à
calculer ça pendant trente quarante
secondes et les deux coups doit être
équivalent à 2,5 et ornée de et
psychologiquement et l'ap tourner autour
prend tout reprend tours 2 ouais je t'ai
dit que c'était bien joué mais en fait
tu en fais quand même faire tourner du
direct et par le retour des hommes et
non ça va quand même effet autour d'eux
pressée farida rahouadj est-ce que tu
prends pages et 3 après royal 3 ouais
donc il va prendre du recul non j'ai pas
il a fait un truc de tête genre il était
très énervé naka mais je sais pas de
quoi il est mort parce qu'il veut faire
oui il est très énervé quel est le
signification de ce mouvement
non mais il a fait un truc genre
deux ratages et il s'est tapé sur la
tête genre en mode je suis très jet vois
pas trop de quoi mettront ils à duras tu
as un truc un iphone il est quand même
mal non avec les noirs bas probablement
tancés de ces super bien joué et on
reprend 1,3 machin des quatre bombes a
essayé de g4 g5 avancé un petit truc
mais bon globalement ça va changer nul
détrompe toi on va peut-être peut-être
un petit peu la joie qu'elle a sa
dépense il fait pas g4 à la fin je vais
te dire ça va s'il te fais le g quattro
aussi pour faire jouer des coups en plus
ça va vite c'est quoi déjà trente
secondes ne faut rien faire d'autre part
j'ai quatre touches à 10
je pense pas être face j'ai cadré oui je
pars si ya ceux qui se barrent
d'écoeurer parti ennahda qui se marrent
est très heureux l'histoire où je
faisais partie du parti dans sa cuisine
je pense à le soulever de tir trouve que
ça serait beau quoi
rage quit ouais non il revient il rien
[Musique]
ces véhicules
bon après c'est pas grave ça fait perdre
deux minutes de match c'est pas ça qui
change la face du monde mais bon non non
c'était pas censés devoir non voilà en
faudra un arbitre qui soit qui juste
stop en fait jean côté une touche
spéciale arbitre quoi or de trésor aft
qui n'a pas pensé mais tu vois ça c'est
vraiment moche enfin je trouve que en
fait le gca trouve c'est déjà moche mais
je trouve que le g5 ça dépasse tout
parce qu'en fait c'est comment dire
assaut il y pense même pas en fait à
dessein que c'est pas un coût des
chèques non pas tu me diras il m'a fait
la même quand je le conduis ya deux
jours il m'a gagné les deux cavaliers
contre pions fou quoi il m'a fait tomber
par mois juste équilibre en v5 pour
faire nul et il m'a fait tomber
qui fait ça comme ça va il pense que
c'est normal enfin oui 40 secondes
devant un vrai chic et par contre si tu
fais ça je pense que tu vraiment
réellement tu t'en prends une en fait je
pense juste non je n'en avais je tort
mais je pense qu'ils les fassent un fab
libye fait ça je pense lui en veux mais
juste une en fait tu eu connaissance est
possible à mon avis juste qu'on voit tu
es où bravo que je suis a fait nul je
suis disqualifié mais pas de chance pour
moi mais globalement c'est pas juste on
fera du lattay 45 heure de jeu devenu le
ferait un tour normal mais c'est tout il
sait mouiller qui contrecarre pas de
chasse à bien se passer a chance contre
carpates chat je pense tu sors pas de la
pièce en fait voilà c'est là que tu
comprends que oui bon tu as gagné
rip quoi reste in peace
non mais c'est là c'est vraiment le g5
autant jusqu'au g5 sarr avait le g5 est
vraiment dégueu parce que comme celui-là
c'est vraiment plus des échecs même son
adversaire il le il y pense même pas
c'est comme moi le truc des deux
cavaliers en fait tu as mais silva
pression sur d'autres navigateurs il
s'en fout il va sur 10 car je crois que
je sais pas où ah oui à combien devront
quitter la zone de jeu c'est génial quoi
il va attendre d'avoir une seconde il a
il a compté les cinquante coups et tous
et à cga mes sauts vraiment il s'est
vraiment déconnecte nouvelle étoile est
vraiment sorti du truc quoi c'est
marrant une nouvelle partie pierrot par
bon c'était 198 coups de folie en grand
plaisir sur sa santé car il fait glisser
çà le blitz les gens s'il te plaît
respecte le blitz entre carinci respecte
talent et respect avec les grands
joueurs du blitz c'est pas ça ça c'est
pas du mx1 c'est dégueulasse juste
bon écoute
ouais c'est sensé mais ça fait le truc
c'est que ça fait sortir tout le monde
du match les joueurs parce que ce sera
fait sortir match nous aussi les
spectateurs tout le monde puisque c'est
vrai que c'est c'est complexe
c'est meilleure forme possible bien sûr
non mais là en plus on fera et je pense
qu'on est fonds sera pas bien sûr ce
qu'on a quand même perdu du temps
précieux par apparaître sûreté rajouter
nous mêmes sur ceux en vrai pour te dire
la vérité sur ce match là ça me
dérangera pas que ça dure cinq heures
non mais en cinq sets gagnants tu vois
pour ça non mais pour un truc longs mois
je pense à nous donne tous envie d'être
pour wesley quoi par un juge comme ça en
fait brufau pourquoi bons sondages
s'appelle comment non moi je veux pas
participer au sondage à je suis dans le
dur il n'y a pas un cavalier g6 à ce que
j'ai demandé parce que fou prend pions
prend t il paiera il a raté une ak47
karma sutra de j'ai envie de te dire red
tape à aimer le kama sutra d' parce que
parce que ce domine ce domine car
magistrats puisque sony j'avais préparé
avant le match des petites notes
ouais ça là j'avais préparé car estrade
parce que ces eaux de vie j'avais
préparé ouais j'en suis content en train
de réparer mon ordi j'ai trouvé cette
petite punchlines josua tiendra le match
je vais regarder un peu le chat est ce
que le chat à tanger pas j'ai pas eu le
chat au monde les sorties au château il
est heureux de cette blague
ouais rien qu'il écrit jolie oui mais
oui elle est très belle salle la haye
ces moules qui l'a mis à les noter sur
le carnet à ses carnets punchline car
red
terrible vous avez quand même bien reigl
lanaken ouais mais tu vois ça c'est fait
on est pour personne mais là ça fait
plaisir non voilà tu es content là bas
les contenants venir aux femmes il est
content la vie kg 600 fuselées vince
tente c'est vraiment le karma qua non
mais ok ça t'apprendra à faire ça parce
que là le truc de jouer g5 de compter
les coûts et où c'était vraiment too
much
c'est génial qu'il est tellement énervée
voix silva le mater comme une merde il
faut mater préfère qu'on y'a pas toi
pranger cette dame jessains haye adam g
6 il s'est fait arnaquer bon mais au
pire définit plus comme attend ici l'été
a mené 5-6 quoi et ça m'embête mes lordi
met un petit coup d'ordi variantes non
alors dame de cinq noms je sais pas
pourquoi mais 2005 2010 le coût qui
gagne pour hg 6,9 à oui ok enfin facile
tant pranger set d'un match si ce brevet
de truc moi je voyais tempo mais qui
marchent pas c'est peut- on prend des
deux machines
c'était tourache 8 twh et c'était tout
oui votre truc vous sont proches des
attentes et les sapins et ses fesses
avec si tu trouves % tu vas trouver le
truc tf1 encore la finir quidam des
indes à main d'homme g5 way peut-être
d'amiens pour tenir f2
key a aussi il ya aussi dame g5 f6
d'alger cet échange les dames on a
besoin de se refaire même a aidé à mach
4 attend et tours 17
c'est tour g8 tout reprend g8 comprend
g8 mat avec le clonage ça fait plaisir
quand en fait c'est vrai que ce serait
moins moche de faire le sale ailleurs je
serai moins grillé quoi tu pourrais dit
richard séchage pour sa survie qui est
composé de défoncer pp la fédé log je
pense je vais être démons k w et non pas
du voyage mais un petit attends moi j'en
vois un bas qui j'envoie un bas qui
j'envoie débat qui quelques voeux à
temps j'en vois ça il ya des batteries
bruel qui partent
je peux mettre quoi encore
je mets un drapeau avec du temps je suis
content c'est quoi cette nouvelle route
c'est une rose du pakistan tu veux tu
joueras des roses attend faut que je les
trouve à main s'il n'est pas mais je
peux envoyer des cris corps je peux
envoyer j'envoie j'envoie des manu
ferrara j'envoie des samoa temps est-ce
que l'on va du pas du samu tient à
tanger en voit un peu du samu j'en vois
deux trois trucs là pour après on est
bien pour on peut retomber hockey lch en
va des roses genre de dragon
[Musique]
j'envoie des apps est aussi une femme
mûre de rose on peut faire un mur de
rose
ouais ça m'a l'air intéressant c'est un
petit mur de roswell et ça fait du bien
mais maintenant le mur de rosie fait du
bien maintenant je pense qu'on vit dans
un monde d'amour et que ce mur de rose
fermiers et nos regrets oui ça symbolise
l'amour du chat mais peut-être quand
même quelques barbelés pour sow ambühl
est aussi le pas et c'est bien là on
sent mieux la sas a manqué non ouais
c'est un peu triste parce que j'ai que
bon la france est partie on a bien mis
des murs c'est mieux maintenant elle a
tout d'un coup on souffle on souffre par
exemple ça fait du bien on n'était pas
bien avant qui quand il dit ça je suis
pas bien
ces chiffres on voit de partout des
trucs après il se sent beaucoup mieux
mais j'avais pas compris à quel point tu
pouvais te sentir mieux après l'avoir
fait avant je me disais non en fait ça
en fait je me sens vraiment mieux tammy
le mur talent et rose un peu partout tu
souffles quoi peut-être un peu de
barbelés tata des trucs qui partent
c'est ça détend quoi on est les seuls à
faire les trucs aussi con mais mais ça
dépend vraiment non mais tu vois c'est
des trucs en fait il pense pas mais ça
détend tu te sens mieux après l'autre ça
calme quoi déjà bien mais si vous voulez
du parquet par bull et maxime faber a
tort quand titi ça
alors cette partie alors encore des
footeux qui l'opposé à noter dur à
évaluer j'aimais bien les blancs et
maintenant je sais pas je pensais même
pas bien et noir ben je suis pas bien
sûr en fait fab ouais on veut plus être
la même position du coup oui c'est très
bien ça c'est vraiment bien sans rigoler
les gens si vous voulez vous entraîner
sur des positions les joué plein de fois
c'est vraiment une bonne idée c'est un
vrai entraînement ou l'associé pas sur
sow qui a fait une tête superbe is an
après d'amasser 6 kg cette même ces
scènes de batailles willaey les dorés
mais je parle d'être le match est très
tendue psychologiquement et du coup tu
vois des trucs au moment de jouer que tu
vois tu ce que bon je pense que le donne
et on fout sur le cavaly on s'en fout
tougas blanche des blancs il a peur non
plus un génie façon j'ai l'impression
que tu veux il ya que les noirs non
qu'ils peuvent vraiment pressé faire ici
je fais b 6 à 5 admettons enfin dans un
monde toujours un lointain monde
j'ai mes pions sur noir je te bloque sur
blanc en neige ou la colonne d accueil à
8 km belles robes et 6 a
vraisemblablement mais il veut aller au
bout des six des sept autres occasions
très jeune j'ai aucune idée du basket et
8 mai quoi faire ensuite
makaay hanouna il ya m l'adar kaka en
tête tu veux c'est 8 e set ces six
grosses d'arca qui arrive la fab à ces
territoires où la d'arcade sorti mais
c'était quoi g4 en fait mais chez ces
l'adar cas du sénat d'artillerie
cavailles hanouna qui s'annonce yves
caillaud 5 et g5 et quelque part faire
un échec
ouais mais bon c est la grosse parka non
parce qu'elle est cette fois bien
colmaté tout ce qui est vrai mais c'est
pas juste bien avec les noirs bah je
préfère non seulement c'était la menace
de d'hanouna qui arrive quoi
shocking stand du joueur américain fasse
face à la puissance de cyril quoi dégage
il faut jamais jamais jamais sous
estimer la puissance d'hanouna j'aime
pas trop fait le plein mais là je sais
pas trop c'est un peu la merde
bref c'est pas le nom mais en fait j'y
peux rien à voir quand il ya un hanouna
qui arrive je sois prêt mais la souris
est dégoûté mais qu'en fait on fait de
la merde c'est sérieux h3 franc jeu 6/3
6/7 collecte en fait qui est des cinq
qui a aidé cette curieuse 500 truqués
tout c'est tellement logique
as tu défends tout volare fuite des
forages 7,7 a besoin de plus 17 en plus
ce que c'est fini ouais
time's up la grosse d'arc a damé là il
n'a pas utilisé hanouna c'est bien fait
pour lui tu as hanouna sur la touche
donc tu ne lie pas de gagner tu n'es pas
les mettre là d'arca tu as perdu
on est quand même déçu sauvage que c'est
un petit peu plus pour le un poussin sur
sa même se passer pour lui ça
malheureusement ouais j'ai trouvé
légèrement plus fort honnêtement femmes
c'est pas toi tu crois que ça sur les
sur cèze sûr c'est sur ces deux heures
trente de match j'ai trouvé un peu
supérieurs wesley ouais je sais pas trop
c'est très équilibré mais mais il a bien
joué il a fait honneur après on va voir
si on peut s'en sortir en bullet sets
très durs mais qui ça ça va être très
très tendue
paraître complexe je suis là complexe
tomber ce couple s bahn qui partent bien
je sais pas trop comment c'est possible
le train najjar 70/30 s'est même déplacé
objective ouais nakai vraiment trop
forts ces 85 15 ou 90 ou en salle
tant besoin
ça va reprendre à mon avis à 55
j'imagine mais comme une partie de
budget en gros on ne mélange des rames
entre 8 et 9
entre huit et dix semaines j'irai enfin
ça dépend vraiment ça va être sympa en
tout cas il n'y a pas de problème de
caméra régler c'est sûr que je briguerai
pas bien parce qu'en fait des fois est à
des gens qui partent qu'ils reviennent
chez eux parce qu'ils font ibug et du
coup ça re décale toutes les caméras
c'est pour ça que j'ai buggé en fait
tout à l'heure c'était fin à l'explosion
ouais ouais c'est ça mais pourquoi n'y a
pas que deux caméras surtout parce qu'en
fait comme ils veulent que les gens ils
ce qu'alice comment dire comme ils
veulent que les gens is comme tu as
beaucoup de gens qui se connectent
pacifique un gars qui étaient connectés
au truc qui se déconnectent c'est ça
fait tout ça peut ça peut
potentiellement tout faire décaler pour
ramener cette option sur zoom juin que
l'organisateur et puis souhaitons c'est
top comme ils veillent et que rien ne
bouge
ou alors juste utiliser un truc mieux
que vous après moi je connais pas trop
ce qui existe
ou alors avoir un truc dédié tu vois
pour le truc
l'adar qu'a fait la dark à dallas être
cette terrible pour s'auto s'est très
bien battu mais dommage on verra j'ai un
sms de chronopost
je pouvais de la route sera livré le
disent c'est quand le dit c'est demain
c'est demain
c'est une bonne nouvelle très bonne
nouvelle parce que là honnêtement hé
ouais c'est quand j'ai un peu blitz
avant et tout s'est vraiment complet que
là j'ai commencé un peu à m'habituer set
up mais bon ces facettes à l'an
cauchemardesque
c'est le vieil ordi que tu avais déjà la
montagne ou quoi ouais ça il a bien sûr
les situations sont nés de ouf enfin
genre là aujourd'hui ce qu'enfin les
gens ne se rendent pas compte mais avec
avec les calmes et tous les trucs qui
affaires vont mieux deux trois premiers
micro mono stéréo et tout ça mais ça
c'est des bugs avec obs ou quoi mais là
le truc qu'on est en train de faire
faillite sauf vraiment la mise en douce
pas le seul bug qu'on a eu c'est une fin
c'est lié un bug de quelqu'un d'autre
qui a fait qu'en réaction en chaîne ça
nous a pris des essais comme le truc des
fusées exemple on va être tous les
toutous les composants et dans une
chance sur un million d'êtres difficulté
mais en fait si on a un qui est un tout
petit peu défectueux qui est un petit
peu chaud du coup on fait par effet
cascade il augmente les chances des
autres on va le réseau thé ouais voilà
c'est un peu pareil en fait c'est les
autres qui bug en premier comme moi je
suis vraiment à la limite mais ce moment
ce soir des fusées je ne sais pas si on
a parlé ensemble ou quoi mais j'ai
entendu ça y'a pas longtemps mais parce
qu'en fait on garde les mêmes vidéos
sûrement pour garder même chaîne youtube
mais ça va participation doit savoir sur
charles gave et c'est de guérir wiki est
passé 2,3 fois dehors j'étais très
heureux
tu avais un peu je pensais que tu es
très heureux s'ils ont un peu de
guillaume rouvier bombe a fait huit
cents très bien quoi
d'ailleurs j'ai d'autant plus regarder
quand c'était guillaume rouvier et ça
joue ça c'est pas les autres en a un peu
marre quand guillaume rouvier dans tous
les ans pareil tu vois tu vas pas donc
là tu dis ah tiens il est venu c'est un
peu le vlad du truc quoi oui bien parce
que là bas c'était charles
ouais mais en fait non c'est game over
oui mais je crois qu'il est complètement
le même profil psychologique que vlad
quoi il faillit des trucs avec beaucoup
d'assurance qui offrent sont pas du tout
vrai mais comme vlad quoi oui mais j'ai
toujours su j'ai toujours dit c'est très
très clair tout le monde sait que
j'adore quoi sert un blad oui mais donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont entendu parler
mais j'ai envie de te dire que la passer
un très bonne c'est un très bon
parallèle avec mon problème de stream
c'est qu'en vrai c'est parce que moi
j'ai une chance sur cinq de bugs et en
fait sur rajoute un problème au dessus
je passe à une chance sur deux quoi mais
du coup ton ordi et identifie fragile
ah non pas du tout plus tu le cas ce
mois il marche quoi c'est très fragile
serait beau que mon nouvel ordi je vends
de vivres à haïti lentilles fragile on
va le balancer du cinquième étage si je
ne le ferai pas je ne recevrai pas cet
ordi c'est un homme fragile sa famille
sont en friche match non mais j'adore
quand il explique le truc d'anti fragile
très intéressant comme concept oui enfin
ça n'existe pas en fait qu'est ce qu'ils
regardent ça car des photos sur son truc
tu vois ce que regarde sa santé quand
même pas regardé photo population j'ai
regardé plus les regards des fonds
d'écran c'est que c'est chaud dès lé qua
non au début on regarde des photos juifs
à fait calme très attention au type de
photos tu regardes covoiturage essaye de
comprendre lui a dit être très
intéressant c'est des choses alors tous
à des montagnes
je paye écrit iia sur la photo qui
regarde un an avant
[Musique]
j'ai pas regardé regard vraiment une
galerie photos ouais je passais fond
d'écran ou quoi j'en sais rien c'est
vrai ça fait super chiant
en fait oui ça va c'est un film à il
regarde les photos d'un film en fait
c'est très heureux jean résister à
vannes à camurac explique ce soit bof ça
se regarde en arrière je suis pas allée
très heureux il ya les photos du film en
fait c'est marrant ben pas marrant
sacamerd se prépare est beaucoup plus
sérieusement là ils sont vous filer la
carence des trucs du film ils
regardaient des extraits du film i
trésor réclame de simon je sais pas quoi
de faire un label sur skype on sait pas
trop ce qui se passe
et quant à 2009 sur son passé au bon on
va pas tarder à la colle donc demain
gérard une journée 2-2 ou encore lord
reading sa terrible bas demain moi ces
deux premières journées les jours depuis
mais du coup tu vas faire pas tu vas
travailler un peu non je peux tout ce
que je veux faire preuve au plus grand
chose non là demain par exemple j'ai
moins assuré qu'aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui en fait j'ai fait la même
chose genre de 8h30 à enfin entre régler
le truc est streamé mais sauf
qu'aujourd'hui j'étais en mode défensif
j'aime pas c'est psychologiquement c'est
un peu comme c est que tu défends un
truc tu vas tu essayes de sauver un truc
et demain je suis en mode
enfin offensif il faut être sûr règle le
problème du coup je pensais plus enfin
c'est beaucoup plus agréable en fait
qu'en fait tu installes les trucs le
truc qu'il avance et puis tu as to this
règle
rab demain j'aurai des trucs à faire
quand même jeu flower à wesley
d'ailleurs dû à wes et qui n'est pas
connecté en ouest ben non il est auto
ouais mais il encore sur les photos y a
pas vu que c'était parti
mais vraiment en fait et là pas du tout
vu que ça commençait rolala mes envies
de jouer la demi-finale sur 10 noté mois
sauf si vous payez s'en fout
complètement quoi ah tiens a vu que ça
avait commencé avant ça le fait marrer
[Rires]
oui on voit ça à bugger en plus son truc
de chaises comme et oui donc sarah et
roland larigot la faune 1 mais oui on
l'a pas prévu que ça a joué en fait la
partie allait s'élancer tout seul était
pas dessus il y a un truc quoi fin des
séries mais est ce que tu penses que le
fait qu'ils regardaient truc quoi serge
henry sait que nakai tellement forts en
bulles est que tu avais créé aucune
chance j'aurais dit sun en fait sous
dans sa croyance que guitry croyez en
dieu
peut-être qu'ils croient tout est déjà
écrit en fait qu à faire son mieux mais
que c'est hyper c'est que c'est comme ça
s'il ya une fille comme ça je sais pas
peut-être que juste s'en fout car il
faut tout pas ça va pas influencer sur
le match c'est très probable qu'il passe
un truc comme ça aussi quoi bon en tout
cas il ay l'a350 point de lots - ambühl
est alors comme dirait maxime qui joue
ses matches là c'est pas du vrai bullet
mais quand même un petit peu disons
aussi ses 100 ou 150 points oui mais 356
quand même beaucoup
on va voir à présent la position est
bizarre avec des pions triplé des pions
doublait pour les blancs les pions de
plus d'options à travers plusieurs
thèmes en mode macro à lens également
fait je prendrais quand même les blancs
je suis là
acton évaluation mais je pense que je
serais plutôt côté blanc à jouer parce
qu'en vrai les noirs n'ont même pas trop
de gagner les blancs non plus en fait
mais c'est plus et noir 3 qui ferme le
jeu pour wii
après je me sens que si tu la presse
avec les blancs tu peux très bien la
perdre tient bon il prend pas mal de
risques un nom même temps pour le non
mais c'est pas trop quoi dire de faire
pour le blogueur j'allais dire si tu es
fou et f5 food et 6 oui non mais je suis
d'accord tu es probablement pas tu
progresses quand même foule mais le fou
indécis c'est un progrès à d'autres
juste pour c'est comme ça progrès par
rosa ne suis pas suffit pas tant qu on
vraiment un truc et ça c'est intéressant
mais cavaliers 7 à obama veut dire au
moins ça change un truc ça marche pas du
tout pas vous avez pas mauvais en soi
juste faire un nul mais en fait oui tu
peux rien y faire mais ce que n'a qu'à
pas tenter de la gagner n'est trop de
temps ouais mais je pense que c'est ce
genre de position ou celui qui tente
père celui qui va enfin il est blanc non
mais j'ai ensuite à bussereau d'un côté
en fait tu vas finir par la perdre
ça va mieux
donc du coup deuxième partie du match
bon bah c'est très chaud quoi c'est
complètement en égalisant pour le moment
mais ça va jouer ya beaucoup de pièces
sur l'échiquier encore mais je sais ce
que je vaux bien les noirs malgré les
dires les noirs sont bien sortis mais
bon j'aime bien parce que c'est bien je
fais une petite sur le tce adversaire
donc d'une petite cible sur laquelle
taper et blanc pas grand chose mais est
pas tellement de projets dans
l'opposition ouais nan t'as raison le
pion b3 un peu faiblard peu arriérée
coiffer même pas un peu ils n'arrivaient
pas à suffire pour gagner mais ça suffit
a pressé tu peux te dire un cheval en
effet si ce nom un jour tu amènes à vous
verser 2 1 jour y'a pas tour un but qui
avait lieu 4k et prend le cadre d'un
projet de way heureusement qu'il avait
ça je suis pas si la évident avance je
sais pas bousquet jouer soi-même en
justice un jour faire gaffe aussi eu sa
voix rauque et colmatent leucatois nakai
mais la marche en avant au centre et il
n'arrive pas à jouer les cases nom et
aussi pour se faire des petits trous
j'en ressens que c'est un cas qui a
mieux géré sa toile nathan il veut d'amd
8 peut-être un moment donné revenir vers
f6 noms doivent à trois ils partis là
bas
oh quel fou c6 j'aime bien moi tu mets
une tour catégorie 3 ouais je mets une
pression
ouais tour à 3 mais fou c'est de bien
jouer un démon qui peut-être tour à doha
est ce que j'allais dire et ça c'est ce
que tu disais le pion des six qui va se
faire attaquer damev 6,6 contre attaque
en f4 voilà c'est chaud c'est chaud
allez il attaque le fou tour aérien et
la table ouais tu peux rien prendre
c'est terrible wen en lan à cana car il
est vraiment mais tellement bon bref
dans cette structure qui pour rien
perdre
ouais et puis en plus et du coup il
réussi à anticiper les coups de
l'adversaire à lui joué tempo à [ __ ]
là a foutu foot là d'arcade ou coucou
temps franck b3 puis on prend aussi si
on prend ouais ça là c'est vraiment le
joug naka il va être plus fort sans
arrêt avait fourchette ouais 3g cette
cavalerie 6 très forts écarts ou higuain
ruud j'ai peur que j'ai peur qu'ils
soient vraiment trop fort le streamer
américain bah je pense très
impressionnant un club en fait du coup
il peut vraiment toujours tout et
n'importe quoi et va toujours avec le
bordel un mouvement et qui peut rien
faire en fait tu peux rien faire il est
trop il est trop fort en il est trop
fort dans le petit jeu quoi c'est pour
ça qu'il fallait vraiment qu'il au moins
un ou deux points d'avance somme m6 à
mon avis ça suffisait pas mais
[Musique]
là non plus il n'a pas forcément le
style so pour vraiment envoyer et met en
danger
ben oui je sais j'ai en plus que au delà
du fait que l'autre sauf que d'un cas
soit forts en bulles est il ya aussi le
fait que en plus sonaca il a le style
qui convient aux bulles est alors que
sonne n'a pas qu'après même le truc plus
profond du bullet il est en faveur de
naka mais pas gros sacrifices en plus il
a ce côté là prendre ses décisions
pratiques comme ça d'après li vraiment
spécialiste de la cadence 1 puisque le
bullet ça joue pas tout à fait comme le
reste est du coup a failli sait prendre
ses décisions spécifiques aux bulles est
alors ça n'a aucun avantage c'est que tu
vas peut-être mes vêtements un bien
finalement avec les blancs fermant bien
ça attendant conclut peu trop facile à
perdre
fatiha juste échangé les tournantes et
orane ont ils fait ça mais roi des sites
là tu peux pas être un héros assez si tu
veux tour c'est peut-être juste puisque
j'ai dit reçut l'ace 3 des 5 3 e 4
maintenant tu attends de 30 secondes
marrant il ajoute quand même me suis tu
peux te
bon encore une phase pas très
passionnant je pense ouais je vois pas
comment tu peux tu peux rien faire avec
les blancs 1 et qui avait pas les fous
tout raide et 5 comprend rodez 4 même y
aller fouiller les coûts mais
probablement que ça dépassera pas 50
coups parce que des cinq adresses qui
est première de faire et puis a pas une
enfant de 15 à 10 h 4 e smith bouquet et
puis a pas énormément de cas sur
lesquels tu peux bouger avec ton tout
sans prendre de risques je veux pas
laisser fouiller cette fois à troyes
genre de trucs bon ça fait toujours un
point je vais regarder un petit je
regarde le chrono là pas loin
il reste vingtaine il faut vraiment
vraiment qu'il revienne vite en bas il
va se jouer au camp rock imagine donc on
va prennent à kayes qui va être en
gestion ou quoi malgré un grand écho six
cavaliers sait très bien jouer il va
faire quoi f5 qu'il va envoyer du jeu
quatre tailles c'est bien joué ça j'ai 4
kg trois thématiques e mail
[Musique]
ça peut causer sicilienne la peau de
michael wallace le 4-2 de 5 2 5
mais ça c'est pareil c'est une nouvelle
fois ses positions sur un an 5 + 1 le
l'évaluation va pas être la même quand
un plus un nom alors que ça s'est
vraiment passé blanc 1 + 1 c'est pas
facile de donner certaines initiatives
que ouais en bullet c'est très important
à jouer l'initiative est justement dans
cette nature inhérente du joueur c'est
plus un tipi canal cassos c'est un peu
comme comme si on changeait de surface
au tennis en réalité ça c'est que tu as
des joueurs tu vas très fort sur terre
battue d'autres plus fort sur gazon et
célia la nature inhérente de leur jeu et
surtout reprendre ce sens qu'il ya une
idée de marloux non je m'en excuse main
car il y ait quatre échanges et à
l'épandage de
et rebondir vers f3 omc qui devrait pas
mais entre 5 et 6 août et sont ils
parlent acheter un truc moi j'aime pas
lâcher des pions centre comme ça mais
c'est pas si bon d'un autre côté tu vas
y va il va avoir un raid à mach 3 et 4
pour protéger le pion et 3 c'est bien
joué
oula oula va se méfier c'est nous qui
avons à wimb à 3.8 y avait un clouage
n'induit ouais ouais mais d'en refiler
un pion est pas bien on va essayer le
scénario de match était écrit dans du
papier de verre
fab sortie ouais ça sentait bon c'est
pas pour rien que macca il ay là il a
joué la pendule en trois plus un an 5 +
surtout en trois puissances on sait que
votre audi l'a fait une fois à 95
peut être bien mais c'était pas trop
choquant comme entre autres hommages 554
ça se tient pas mais bon ça peut
peut-être quatre contre trois joueuses
très bien joué de la part de naka que la
faiblesse machin il et il est très fort
il est très fort le streamer
le pion à a3 et tu te fais un tour 17 et
u avec les décident de faire un à trois
bon je passe sur kiss mais je sais pas
si quelqu'un qui peut trouver défend
bien en tout cas
ouais c'est aussi pour le truc ses
lectures à 5 la tourache 4 et tour h3 et
tout reprend mais on peut pas rentrer
dans la finale pour y arriver
rob écueil tour tour d'être au cours des
trois quatre destins est à parois prend
1,4 à roye prendrait le dessus et on
apprend des cats a perdu pendant 3 prend
des cadres bancaires en europe en cours
oui et non ça j'ai vu mes joueurs on
apprend des 4 il n'a pas fait mais oui
un peu trop juste il joue statu quo ils
sont fous bon ça c'est bon ça c'est ici
ça va s'y soient sincères vont être tu
vas faire échec à si tu peux bon ils
sont rapides
ah oui là ils aillent là il a raté les
trucs bon après ok mais bon avec 3
secondes je préfère le concret très bon
normalement ces jobs l'auteur way i ve
apte à jouer pendant longtemps et s'est
fait refaire l'erreur
le mauvais prêts move quoi parce que
c'est lui qui a la main des prêts move
pressé mérité un hilal pion de plus cela
donne le droit de te faire souffrir
c'est pas comme tout à l'heure en ce cas
là ils essayent de gagner en réalité
il essaie de gagner sa radio rai des
plombes
la rater ouais c'est même ça depuis cas
ici même ça ils la gagnent là après la
après c'est vraiment là c'est vraiment
inhérents à la cadence 1 c'est pas du
tout inhérents au dail la raison de la
jouer à fond c'est nul mais tu as raison
weissbach la sauce et c'est parti cette
arrivée est parti dans sa cuisine
ouais pas dans sa cuisine gisant à green
mais j'imagine je pense qu'il a compris
que le match était perdu en fait s'en
fout ayem est ce un plus à la fin
favorise vraiment rona cas il ya que
karlsson qui peut qui peut le prendre un
plus un mois je la trouve beaucoup trop
longue perso moi je mettrais dix minutes
un plus un puisque mais bon vraiment
pour départager deux trois parties de
dix minutes ça ferait ouais ça ferait
trois parties je trouve trois quatre
parties ce serait bien de match voilà
oui le ring et je devrais peut-être pas
autant tout miser là dessus ça aurait
rendu le match plus intéressant
effectivement de se dire parce que je
vous la montre à ce point ou quoi c'est
pas non mais il a il a très très bien
géré son match wesley qui a entre
guillemets risa enfin quand tu te lèves
40 secondes pendant un but est pour moi
tahri zain le match donc ouais nan on à
canach impressionnant sauf j'espère
quand même légèrement supérieure en
blitz très légèrement mais sur
l'ensemble du match
naka dans tous les cas mérite largement
sa victoire
on parle comme si c'était fini a que
deux points d'écart mais ah bon avant
même que la session commencée les pas de
suspense mais bon là oui avant que ça
commence
350 points d'écart dans la cadence
énormèment m6 a le plus sain comme on
disait mais c'est quand même quelque
chose
mallet ci sauve gagner celle-là ça
pourrait faire tilt
salah est peut-être là la partie qui
peut qui peut le relancer
il reste qu il reste treize minutes vont
si la paire c'est vraiment des dead sea
fait nul c'est quasi dead dead sea la
gagne ça redonne un microscopique
espoirs basse il se dit je peux gagner
en partant 40 secondes deux mois un
centre de coûts un coup de boost mais
moralement nice c'est pour ça que je la
dis ça d'accotement raison dans un final
est mieux pour lui menaka quand même
quel marlou avec avec le tour pions
était tellement dur à jouer plus d'un
coup mais là ce il fait une bonne partie
mais il va finir par la faire annuler
d'ailleurs que nul ça lui laisse la
microscopique chances des fêtes c'est
vraiment fini tant des auteurs je
comprends pas il veut dire que le fou
sort pas bottes il fait rien en fait ah
non il y avait différents thèmes ça tu
peux quand même la perdre avec et noir
n'ont et le machin à huy et du coup il a
fait retour à 2 et bien voilà mon fab
c'est la défaite de trop pour wesley
très dominés dans l'institutionnel je
pense qu'ils en roue libre
il doit être content quand même parce
qu'on a senti que qu'il était sous
pression pendant le match mais je sais
pas s'il sera encore plus fort que ces
joueurs là pendant encore longtemps dans
ce format la maca je pense que d'ici à
deux ans il va commencer à se faire
rattraper écoutons qu'il a sa bouée de
sauvetage de bullet
après faut voir s'ils veulent pas
modifier le format on sort jamais sur
plus fort mais ça serait un truc des
yeux mais en blitz en tout cas il n'a
plus la même marche qu'avant non par
rapport à ce oui mais pas sûr que ces
tours précédents de la marche ouais
après fait de cf c'est difficile de
juger un mec sans connexion machin nom
l'évoqué quand mes notes 0 kas connexion
pa kone sur ma chaise il ya une marge
ah oui non mais non mais ça on est 100 %
d'accord il ya une marge et une marge
mais je veux dire par là à quel point
les grandes ça c'est peut-être c'est pas
du neuf zéros ce que je voulais dire
bon ce que vous restez va réussir à
gagner salah et mettre une once
d'incertitude où un podium
moi non plus mais bon quand je vais
retourner huit noms un peu que c'est con
mais c'est le matin et cas je crois j'ai
quatre c'est terrible ça peu ambitieux
s'il était acceptable
c'est un peu too much au cours des six
ou quoi bien joué ça va piquer
l'occasion wes équivalent a regagné
récemment il est vraiment infernal
s'arracher 500 g 8 à c y rigole maca
la jouer jusqu'au bout un ça pas grand
chose pour être bien sûr il a vu un pad
possible en jeu la pendule à fond il te
joue la pendule à fond il reste quoi
huit minutes il reste trois parties mais
celle qui revient un peu
mathématiquement c'est pas fun il
voulait être bien sûr un quand même il
est une bonne position et un hollande
est ok s'ils gagnent salaires via un
point
et alors là ont séparé il ya une vieille
partie cheer up assez jolie dans une
position comme ça où il donne la qualit
en a et a pris des fonds sur les cases
noires puis ça je dis rien les
hollandaises belges et hollandaises et
contre bas relief une vieille partie
joli bas juste va être du coup ils se
retrouvent avec la dame et le fou sur la
grande diagonale il défonce quoi 13h01
en tête de shirov aussi déjà conclus au
pied je crois imaginez avec g3 où cette
fuite deux qualités des cas pour pro 3
prend un moment ait gagné il en a fait
des belles shirov là bas beau joueur il
était chic et numéro deux mondial quand
même c'est pas n'importe qui est-ce que
wesley réussi à mettre en une once
d'incertitude je crois pas c'est
difficile
c'est qu'il a ses quatre cas qui lui a
égalisé en force
et puis en plus c'est bien ce que dans
un cas il aura trois jours pour se
reposer avant la finale c'était prévu
qu'il joue samedi et que la finale soit
dimanche
maintenant il aurait pu être un petit
peu peuplée chalet stone et pourquoi la
teneur des débats dimanche
je sais pas j'ai lu des idées des
informations contradictoires je peux pas
te dire non non elle sera pas dimanche
mais sur le fait qu'elle ne soit pas
dimanche j'ai lu des histoires d
infliger des sanctions contradictoires
donc j'en sais pas c'était prévu devient
patent français quand moi je fais un
tour prend des six mais tu es un peu
moins
oui c'était quand même prévu depuis
depuis on est d'accord c'était prévu
depuis huit mois que ce serait comme ça
veut dire que ce soit compliqué
d'enchaîner deux jours d'hommages de
suite je samedi et dimanche à l'est
admettons mais du groupe mercredi basse
est temps que je passe le dimanche et et
puis pour les joueurs qui jouent
vendredi
c'est mieux qu'un jour de repos plutôt
que de jouer le lendemain
gg je peux pas te dire trop
d'informations contradictoires dans les
échecs ça reste très marginal de finale
dimanche aucune restons dans la norme
bah oui fils lundi ce film marty
après c'est dommage que ça fasse pas le
truc de vendredi samedi dimanche moi
j'aimais bien dans le super week-end
mais je trouvais ça sympa - en vrai nous
offre aujourd'hui un beau samedi et
dimanche oui oui non je crois qu'on s'en
fiche complètement d'accord mais oui je
suis assez à je suis assez at on appris
ce jeudi membres c'est pas beau s'il
veut prononcer vu aucune info de rien
donc les enfants est très correct voire
contradictions du mal à gagner ray ban
mata de l'avant se fasse et le pion
c'est qui va être plus rapide par par
rapport aux options est en fait deux
bon bah sa clôture ce match fab
cette fois ci c'est vraiment finir
espoirs f il reste deux parties max
brail coutts tu as beau match
bon faut encore mieux sans les phases à
faire couler le temps ça vraiment pas
changé l'issue du match peut s'arrêter
plus de place ouais mais bon c'est comme
ça c'est comme ça fabing on refait on
refait pas le match était tout sourire
là y'a un truc qui te fait plaisir
non ce forum social bas on est pas de
débattre ou en question je suis content
la jeune chat aussi faible ce fable qui
qui disaient qu'ils aient joué au ping
pong et jacques chirac en double
moi qui fais pas trop bien et on lui a
dit quoi il n'a pas trop aimé parlant
chirac leurs remarques
ce qu'on est obligé de couper le stream
ensuite vous pouvez pas parler des
interviews tu peux aller les voir les
interviews
ouais sur l'autre celle sur les chaises
k-way nationale et bases de données la
reine qu'il a aujourd'hui d'autres avec
robert wheadon clairement tu peux tu
peux y aller way
or
son saut et varie guère spécial à dire
que l'accueil a été très fort et c'est
même s'il avait gagné il aurait dit que
tu as on a été plus fort que la chance
de gagner et pinnacle à elle va dire la
great match mais ça aurait été mieux
avec vous c'est pour ça ils sont trop
sérieux rence travail mais cette façon
ce qu'ils vont poser les questions donc
on n'y peut rien va non j'étais pas là
faisait un poète satirique cornetto nous
on peut pas faire on peut pas faire
grand chose pour ça non mais en fait ils
prient beaucoup trop sérieux m c'est
simple et ferfay f2 joli joli arrière
pour le pour le match mais c'est joli
bah ça à ce qu'ils finissent à un ou
deux points et ouais c'est joli coucou
c'est pas trop sérieuses et c'est trop
toujours c'est trop consensuelle l'homme
et puis ils sont tous y est tout le
temps ouais et on se marre d'être au
fait mais je me souviens je vis à vis
des highlights de denain café de cfm
c'était bien pas de dire qu'il a fait à
me ranger de a manqué un coup bon assez
spectaculaire mais sauf qu'il ya 24 à 3
coiffe un bon qu'en fait tu regarde même
plus trop si spam et de danse étaient
vraiment excités comme des fous donc
c'est très différent
ouais c'est différent en fait on soit
c'est vrai que c'est un joli coup c'est
intéressant comme parti et je trouve que
le contexte influence beaucoup ce que
vous ferez d'un match de tennis 6 et 6 0
6 0 5 1 mais ça ne m'est pas comparer un
superbe passing
bon oui bon passing mais qui préfère
comparer puisque le match de tennis ne
serait pas finie
non c'est quand même si un match de foot
à 14 0 et qui ont donné il ya un mec qui
met un but enfin oui il y avait quatorze
héros en fait on à la 89e minute
y'a plus personne dans le stade ça
tourne ses bars et enfin on s'en fout en
fait bon rythme et un beau but
vraiment beau mais il cycle est et c'est
bien mais j'ai du mal à être je prends
tous dia c'est dans ce but que
complètement oui mais pas de noms mais
je dirais et c'est tant mieux donc c'est
sympa voici la voilà ces gens mais c'est
vrai que bon me tiens 14 euros tu dis
bon bah c'est quand même là on fait
chair qui regardent ils sont très
excités bon à le match est fini le match
est fini tu vas passer
ok c'est fini c'est gagner c'est bravo
gg quoi il ya plus de temps ou quoi quoi
que tu fasses tu peux abandonner ou quoi
il n'ya plus d'enjeu le streak est finie
le truc infinie face c'était bien
c'était un beau match pour la peine mais
bon il est passé ça fait vrai mais nous
on a cette vision là c'était un beau
match mais il est fini et encore un
autre vendredi
mais s'il avait fini et du coup alors
qu'hambourg squattant pour vendredi au
maximum le grand favori non bravo à
notre lettre des murs de barbelés tout
ça ça va le faire ah bah oui il va avoir
les murs et on a les fusées fire a
beaucoup de choses après pour les
joueurs c'est différent parce qu'ils
n'ont pas forcément le chrono ou quoi
donc eu en fait ils peuvent être moins
comment dire en bullet tepa t'as pas
forcément les yeux rivés sur le chrono à
plus de 3h30 de jeu tout le mois du site
us et paul laffont coll ouais ouais
c'est différent pour les joueurs donc
c'était parti pour les gagner mais là ce
qui t'attend gagner celle-là a priori
bas mais il va mourir à un point du coup
donc c'est beau bravo saut après est
toujours difficile à dire à quel point
si le match avait été plus serré mais tu
vois la partie la partie car à 40
secondes et qu'il a perdu finalement il
s'est barré elle est être lourde de
conséquence un français mais oui on
pourra jamais savoir dire que oui parce
que le match serait peut-être passer
autrement et ça change beaucoup de
choses les skis le time's up nagai s'en
fout time's up ou pas je suis tu la
joues et 60 coup tu vas être heureux il
va attendre trente secondes quand même
pour être bien sûr bien sûr parce que le
match est bien fini pour ça que j pour
les joueurs c'est différent non là il va
finir à 1 point son qui sait que le
match est terminé j'imagine mais c'est y
tenait il aurait peut-être mérité mieux
quand même natte wesley bail à la partie
qui viennent pas aussi il s'est déjà
barré c'est génial plus avec la primaube
ceux ci après vous vais mater il s'est
barré quoi ces normes d'artigny vous
il avait une pièce de plus l'algérie
oui mais de gagner aussi
ouais je dirais way sur le match c'est
serré c'est serré jusqu'au bout
sérieux c'est sympa c'était sympa
c'était cool moi c'est le meilleur match
que j'ai vu cette année autres ouais
ouais
a lyon il y en a pas il y en a pas eu
énormément en vrai des beaux matches non
mais mais celui là celui là en fait
partie
très clairement c'est très clairement
cela en fait partie ouest et qui a raté
le coche on l'a sentie entre
à +1 peut-être en 5 + 50 iman en fait de
deux points il doit réussir à ne pas se
remonter il ya eu quelques tournants il
ya eu ça en 5 + 1 et il ya eu après ou à
il s'est fait remonter un deuxième
tournant 3 + 1 où il semblait un peu
plus dominé il n'a pas réussi à
concrétiser en fait gérés il ya deux
moments dans le match où il n'a pas
réussi à avoir à prendre 100% de ses
occases après en revanche en bullet
c'est le contraire il a je trouve qu'il
a un peu surperformé donc après c'est
peut-être ça ce qu'on pense au final non
je pense que ok vainqueurs logiques
vainqueurs mais avec un peu des petits
s'y passe est sûr de gagner
ouais c'est ça c'est que c'était je
crois que le truc de côtes 65 35 en fait
c'est assez juste sur le d'après le
scénario du match
exactement bon festival t'as kiffé de
ouf ou pas non c'était bien se tenir
j'étais prêt pour la finale watch pour
la finale en plus on va pouvoir tester
ton nouvel ordi tout ça est bien donc
donc oui parfait mais la savane on
s'était finalement on a juste eu un
problème à un moment donné mais 6 8 ans
j'ai passé non des jeux bon après j'ai
pas vu autant bouger les pièces que
d'habitude ou quoi parce que je faisais
hyper gaffe que tout marche mais selon
moi je trouve ça cool je vais demander à
6,37 entre ça très bien quoi mais mais
mais je crois que ça va c'était l'armée
s'était pas au ciné théâtre elle affirme
que d'habitude ça va non non c'était pas
ou ici michael que d'habitude matin mais
en fait part par rapport au taux où est
ce qu'on pouvait faire pas parce qu'on
pouvait faire on pouvait difficilement
faire plus bon bah du coup on va on va
on va retrouver patrick bruel allez bon
stream
bonne chance aux jeunes vendredi et
dimanche pour une délicate attend juste
que tu me laisses deux minutes de
meublage parce que je suis raide et où
beaucoup en fait j'essaye devaient tous
mais en fait d'habitude j'arrive à le
faire très rapidement là évidemment bas
je sus
non ok bah je me blesse par les
clochards tout mais c'est vraiment 30
secondes
non mais j'ai rien à faire de spécial
j'ai commandé mes trucs c'est pourquoi
arrivé je prends corps reste un quart
d'heure à mais en fait non de toute
façon le raid est ce que je peux le
faire et on va essayer je sais pas si
maintenant je suis pas coter non écoute
de toutes façons de toute façon je peux
pas faire ce que je veux donc bah
écoutez les gars si vous voulez nous
suivrons va être avec etienne sur ma
chaîne perso blitz trimestre quoique
dans le raid jumeaux des lenteurs
battante je sais pas si tu peux attend
il ya peut-être lui c'est c'est cela
chez red rat idée du coup et est ce
parce bitstream
mais tu peux le faire que dans quelques
secondes je te laisse je te laisse le
temps tu es du coup je déconnais que le
cameroun battu le tente tant que dans
trente secondes hockey bottine moi moi
moi j'étais un tout l'âge et en hockey
[Musique]
et on se retrouve je ferme aussi ton
truc quoi pour pas pour pas tout faire
donc chaofan je te le dis en même temps
savoir à tous et on doit peut-être dans
le train qui du coup pour la des petites
roses voilà tout
merci femmes